hmm yeah hello and welcome to this video
somehow the recordings didn't start
right away it was kind of strange okay
playing and marmalade yeah I'm on Margo
wrong move so look what we get some kind
of multiple fianchetto I don't really
know this lines these lines all that
well they have the same oh that's rare
it's definitely a rare move anyway hmm
but where do you go here if I go queen
age form this age six problem not all
that grade hmmmm where do you do
actually may be here I don't know that's
96 is not a move I'm particularly aware
of that that this is played c4 porn
could be vulnerable
oh that's surprising I don't know if
this is all the great to trade winds but
certainly something I can do doesn't
look wrong in any way so let's see what
happens here 95 and doesn't do all that
much so probably just drop back yeah
it's hard to play this without be three
so I can play nine to five now and see
what happens if he cancels i might have
Bishop g5 hmm it isn't that a little bit
annoying them for him I'm threatening on
f6 and well we takes d5 pawn takes a
seven is under fire he has not before
things but yeah let's see
problem is if de seven drops d6 will
also drop if I take with the bishop only
seven that's not quite clear to me what
he should do now looks looks a bit
awkward for black yeah probably he had
to do this let's see now I mean I'm not
sure how bad it really is for him he has
all kinds of counter text like on e 2
and so on it might be that black is
still ok so i can take both but he
always has rookie ain't down sorry voice
is a bit off yeah I pretty much have to
take I think this is probably not bad
for black he's a reasonably active the
only thing it could be like technically
problematic for him that there are some
some things that don't quite add up
what's going on here I can take a vein
here and tick
if i take c a drupe c8b should be
success 93 ok
we should f-89c one Bishop g7 and it's
sitting in a pin I don't know if
difficult technically really difficult
no he he has to take now and I thought
the night you for keeping his pieces a
little bit stranded nighty choking f1
just loose material so he has to take
ever the king and then 94 was my idea
Kim
not so quick and so not so quick on
night xp3 that will not be five
immediately not be five rupee three 9692
checking f1 bishop a six
I can also go to h1 deep pond looks
pretty dangerous check yeah I thought to
each one if i go to f1 time warning
takes on b3 I always those double checks
that are pretty awkward i play on the
deep on here I don't have a particularly
great square for the night
doesn't quite add up doesn't quite work
unfortunately it wasn't bad certainly
for white at some point but I didn't
didn't play it correctly ranking go I
can do this soon
yeah came that was pretty straight loss
resins pretty stupid loss because quite
clearly black leg must be in some kind
of danger yeah i don't i don't know
maybe okay the engine doesn't confirm my
impression so he is active enough i
thought i should have something here
with the like here i thought i should
have something with those ideas on the
d6 porn which doesn't doesn't quite work
yeah yeah Brooksie one was already
possible this also doesn't really work i
thought the dupont would be dangerous
but it doesn't it doesn't really add up
so that means I'm this Bishop g5 wasn't
wasn't all that great Bishop age three
yeah it's a normal position I mean maybe
wide is slightly better that that the
engine is giving hear that it's
believable but John no I completely West
made it this kind of situation I mean I
wasn't totally sure but I felt it should
be better for wired yeah here you cannot
do anything
if I start with this yeah then he sa six
ok this is what I saw may I six that
make sure that this doesn't work and
then b3 is just weak check it just yet
not work now until the dew point is stop
that he pushes his two connected passes
hmm ok thanks for watching